controversial opinion you should be nice to people
this idea that no one owes anyone anything
I think is bullshit
because quite literally
the only thing that we have in this world is connection with other human beings
and like
that's it so I think actually you do
you do owe people kindness
you do owe people human decency
like that that's literally all that you need to do in this world
I feel like we've been so desensitized as human beings and we become like
so isolated and alone
that we forget that human connection is literally the basis of human existence
like just be fucking nice to people
it's real like
I just I don't know why that is such a difficult concept
like why do we go out of our way to be cruel to people
do we go out of our way to judge others is like I
does it benefit your life to make you feel better
because being a
does it does being a hater like
make you feel better about yourself
I literally don't get it
because I have never had the urge
to comment something nasty on someone's profile
I've never had the urge to like
be mean to someone's face
like I don't understand that
life is so much better when we are kind to people around us and we like
connect with other human being
do you not feel empty inside
like if your entire life is based on judging other people
like the only explanation I have is like you hate yourself
that's the only thing that makes sense
and does that not make you hate yourself more
and if you are a person that hates on other that leaves nasty comments
I really implore you take the week
take the day take
take the day maybe the week and just like be better
be kinder be nicer
when you have a negative thought and wanna voice that
actually take a pause and do the opposite
say something nice
I'm not kidding
choose to be kind
choose to be good to people around you
and you might just have some value in your life now
because I'm so tired of people just being miserable
and then continuing and perpetuating that misery onto the rest of the world
take this opportunity to change that cycle and be better